[Music]
the president has repeatedly talked
about the Russian investigation into the
u.s. or the Russian Russia's involvement
in the u.s. election cycle as a hoax and
as fake news the Russians
interfered in our election during the
2016 cycle they did it with purpose they
did it with sophistication they did it
with overwhelming technical efforts and
it was an active measures campaign
driven from the top of that government
there is no fuzz on that it is a high
confidence judgment of the entire
intelligence community in his interview
with Lester Holt on NBC the president
said I had dinner with him he wanted to
have dinner because he wanted to stay on
is this an accurate statement professor
did you in any way initiate that dinner
no he caught he called me at my desk at
lunchtime and asked me was I free for
dinner that night what was it about that
meeting that led you to determine that
you needed to start putting down a
written record a combination of things I
think the circumstances the subject
matter and the person I was interacting
with circumstances first I was alone
with the President of the United States
and then the nature of the person I was
honestly concerned that you might lie
about the nature of our meeting and so I
thought it really important to document
that combination of things I'd never
experienced before but it led me to
believe I got to write it down and it
got to write it down in a very detailed
way either he had concluded or someone
had told him that you didn't you've
already asked Comey to stay and you
didn't get anything for it and that the
dinner was an effort to build a
relationship in fact yes specifically of
loyalty in the context of asking me to
stay
there he's looking to get something in
exchange for granting my request to stay
in the job this didn't improve the
relationship because it was very very
awkward he was asking for something and
I was refusing to give it you perceived
it as an order given his position to
setting and like in the some of the
circumstances yes I took it as a
direction thing I mean it's the
president United States with me alone
saying I hope this I took it as this is
what he wants me to do I didn't obey
that but that's the way I took it I took
it as a very disturbing thing very
concerning but that's a conclusion I'm
sure the Special Counsel will work
towards to try and understand what the
intention was there and whether that's
an offense president said in one case I
called him and in one case he called me
is that an accurate statement no the
president called the FBI director on two
additional occasions
March 30th and a full 11th and asked him
again quote to lift the cloud on the
Russian investigation now director Comey
denied each of these improper requests
of course after his refusal director
Comey was fired
the president and I had had multiple
conversations about my job both before
and after he took office and he had
repeatedly told me I was doing a great
job
and he hoped I would stay he told me
repeatedly that he had talked to lots of
people about me including our current
Attorney General and had learned that I
was doing a great job I was also
confused by the initial explanation that
was offered publicly that I was fired
because of the decisions I had made
during the election year the
administration then chose to defame me
and more importantly the FBI by saying
that the organization was in disarray
that it was poorly led that the
workforce had lost confidence in its
leader those were lies
plain and simple why do you believe you
were fired I don't know for sure
I believe the president at his word that
I was fired because of the Russia
investigation there's no doubt that it's
a fair judgment it's my judgment that I
was fired because of the Russia
investigation I was fired in some way to
change or the endeavor was to change the
way the Russia investigation was being
conducted that is a that is a very big
deal something about the way I was
conducting it the president felt created
pressure on him they want to relieve
[Music]
do you believe there were any tapes or
recordings of your conversations with
the president it never occurred to me
till the president's tweet I'm not being
facetious I hope there are I was so
stunned by the conversation that I just
took it in and the only thing I could
think to say because I was playing in my
mind because I remember every word he
said I was playing in my mind what
should my response be and that's why I
very carefully chose the words and look
like I've seen the tweet about tapes
lordy I hope their tapes the president
surely knows whether he taped me and if
he did my feelings aren't hurt released
the entire release all the tapes I'm
good with it